foreign
today we are here with the complete
roadmap to become a python developer in
2023 before we start if you enjoy
watching Tech videos and are new to our
Channel then hit the Subscribe button
and press the Bell icon to stay updated
with the latest techmological trends in
the market today we are surrounded by
many applications from the news we read
in the morning to listening to late
night music these applications execute
using a simple programming language
today we will explore one of those
programming language
and that is python if we talk about
python then Python's flexibility
Simplicity and versatility find its way
into these remarkable applications
python is used to create several
commonplace applications including
Spotify and Netflix and python is the
world's most widely used and fastest
growing programming language
and not just among software developers
but also among mathematicians scientists
accountants Network engineers and even
young children they are very familiar
with programming language python many
TDS processes such as coping files and
directories renaming them and uploading
them to a server can be automated with
Python scripts therefore a variety of
professionals and software developers
use Python to automate processes and
improve their lives
you now need to understand the
importance of a python developer and the
Python programming language today
developers are ruling our world so let's
get started with who is a good python
developer to be a good python developer
you will need more than just technical
knowledge and the following skills the
first skill you need to know is you
should have a problem solving mindset
the second skill you need is strong
communication skills you will need to
communicate project requirements and
features to your team this will also
help you write better documentation
the third skill you should have is an
eagerness to learn new tools and
libraries then you should have knowledge
of how things work internally and
definitely strong technical skills
and if we talk about the average salary
for a python developer in India that is
rupees 8 lakh 25 and 593 rupees per year
as stated by indeed.com
today at 21st December 2022 and the
average salary for a python developer in
the United States is 1 lakh
6649 dollars per view and now we will
start with what python is
so python is a general purpose
interpreted programming language during
its extreme versatility python is one of
the most sought after programming
languages by data scientists software
engineers and web Developers
python can be used in a wide range of
disciplines including data analysis
machine learning artificial intelligence
web development web scraping competitive
programming and much more
unsurprisingly given its versatility
python became the most sought after
language to learn in 2021
their specific employment positions and
sectors that a python developer can
pursue depending on the skill set
that is web developers software
Engineers data analysts data scientists
automation testers Etc these are all
python Developers
in the next question that arises in your
mind would be why to become a python
developer when there are so many other
programming languages that may be
learned let's look at some of the
benefits of being a python developer you
should start your programming earlier by
learning python for several reasons
first reason should be python has a
basic syntax and is easily readable
second should be it makes the language
easy to learn for both beginner and
intermediate programmers python is a
multi-purpose programming language with
many practical libraries and outstanding
analytical capabilities a programmer can
devote more time to development due to
these features of python then the third
reason should be python enables
programmers to write programs with fewer
lines of codes python programs for
instance run slower than Java programs
but they also need less time to create
because the python code is three to five
times shorter than the Java
and the next reason should be all
operating systems can utilize python for
free because it is open source software
the next is it is the most productive
language
then we have python has a wide range of
applications and python has a vast and
active community and it has hundreds of
built-in libraries and Frameworks now
moving on python is used by numerous
companies like Google
Facebook Netflix IBM and much more
these companies use Python to develop
software and use them for machine
learning web development and many more
you can see how beneficial learning
python is
now to become a python developer we will
Begin by studying the fundamentals of
Python Programming to master the
fundamentals of python you should study
these subjects
starting with basic syntax then you
should have a Hands-On any code editor
like Wim chipta notebook Google collab
or atom
then you should study the indentation of
Python language
then you should move to loops and
logical operators then we have data
types and variables then operators then
strings and numbers
and then we have conditional statements
and type conversions
and at last
we have functions and built-in functions
now we shall go to Python's most crucial
section that is data structures and
algorithms they serve as any computer
languages building blocks DSA is a
requirement for both coding and software
development interviews to master the DSA
you should learn about these subjects
starting with Aryan linked list
then we should learn binary search trees
and recursion
then we should learn python lists and
tuples then dictionaries sets and
slicing then we have stacks and queues
after that we should learn hashing
hash tables and graph traversing then we
should learn about sorting algorithms
divide and concur algorithms and many
more algorithms then we should have a
Hands-On dynamic programming
after finishing the python DSA we'll
move towards some of the advanced
concepts in Python and the relevant
topics to learn in the advanced topics
are we will start with object oriented
programming then we should learn the
methods
and then we should learn functional
programming and then we have the most
popular element that is inheritance then
we have decorators in Python and then we
have Lambda functions we should learn
how to use Lambda functions in this
language then we have classes and then
the simple and regular Expressions after
having expertise in core python Concepts
you should learn GitHub
do you know that practically all hiring
managers request a gator profile these
days
it is an environment to develop your
online portfolio and highlight your
abilities a GitHub profile makes you
more distinctive from your competition
recruiters will first look at your
GitHub profile when you apply for
competitive positions like data
scientist ml engineer web developer or
python developer it gives potential
employers an impression of your coding
expertise problem solving techniques and
problem solving philosophy you have a
greater chance of standing out if your
guitar profile is up to date and while
maintained without a question knowing
how to use GitHub will help you succeed
in your career GitHub is a platform
millions of developer use to exchange
their code and create online portfolios
after mastering the above Concepts you
can choose a career path that interests
you as a python developer and the
creative parts we have as is web
development as a python developer then
we have machine learning or artificial
initial intelligence expert or engineer
then we have the field of data science
in data science you can pursue data
scientists or data analysis
then we have automation testing and web
scraping so these are the career paths
you can choose after learning these
concepts of python and if we talk about
data science it was rated one of the
hottest fields of the 21st century by
Howard Business Review data science is
an interdisciplinary field that employs
arithmetic statistics and algorithms to
extract useful information from data a
data scientist is a professional with
expertise in data analysis and
interpretation these data scientists
assist firms to make better decisions
and run more efficiently by utilizing
their data science expertise to start a
career in data science you should learn
the following things
starting with libraries such as
matplotlib pandas numpy and Seaboard
then you should learn statistical
analysis
the science of Statistics focuses on
creating and researching strategies for
Gathering analyzing interpreting and
presenting empirical data then you
should have a hands on probability and
mathematical formulas probability is a
way to gauge How likely something is to
happen
then we should have a Hands-On data
visualization data visualization is
integrating different data sets and
creating a visual display of the results
using diagrams charts and graphs then we
should have a Hands-On data manipulation
data analysis and data interpretation
and if we talk about
database management then we should learn
about databases which are necessary to
store and analyze data using programs
like teradata Microsoft SQL Server
Oracle database and MySQL once you have
mastered these skills you will have
various careers opportunities as a data
science expert and the average salary
for a data scientist reported by
indeed.com and 21st December 2022 is
dollar ninety seven thousand and 148 US
dollars
now moving on web development as a
career if you want to pursue web
development then you should have a good
grasp of two Frameworks starting with
Django and flask
if we talk about Django then it's a high
level web development framework mostly
utilized by businesses and startups you
can utilize a variety of databases
including postgresql MySQL SQL Lite and
Oracle and it add ease to the MVC design
it could take two to five weeks to learn
if you are a beginner and unfamiliar
with authentication URL routing API and
models but these take your time to be
patient read through some of the
additional resources and comprehend
every line of code you will get a grasp
of it we will gradually and thoroughly
comprehend everything and one of the
simplest Frameworks to learn in
pythony's flask flask is appropriate for
creating straightforward lightweight web
applications although it lacks Django
strength and breadth it offers
capabilities like support for developing
rest apis and unit testing it will take
1 to 1.5 weeks to non-flask
and then you should have a good command
or front-end technologies that is HTML
CSS and JavaScript and if you want to
build a GUI based web app then you
should have kinter MVC and MVD
architecture
which stands for model view control and
model view template you should have
Hands-On these Technologies and if we
talk about the average salary for a
python web developer that is
dollar 106 comma 649 US dollars per year
in the United States as stated by
indeed.com
and if we move towards the carrier path
in machine learning and artificial
intelligence then
one of the industries with the most
rapid growth is machine learning if you
are interested in pursuing a career in
ml and AI you should learn the following
things starting with apply meds
and States then you should have Hands-On
machine learning algorithms and then you
should learn libraries such as
scikit-learn tensorflow and Keras then
you should have a Hands-On prediction
model
then neural networks for deep learning
and then the natural language processing
and after these skills you can easily
pursue a career in machine learning and
artificial intelligence and if we talk
about the average salary for a machine
learning engineer that is 1 lakh
7856 US dollar per year in the United
States as stated by indeed.com on 21st
December 2022 and if we move about the
career in web scraping and automation
testing we have things to consider while
learning web scripting and automation
testing although python comes with its
own set of test automation Frameworks a
python developer should be familiar with
this concept for better understanding
test transformation enhances your work
as a python developer
as python developer is responsible for
debugging errors tools like selenium
test complete Etc will help increase
efficiency and speed and things to
consider while learning web scraping and
automation testing are we should start
with web scraping using beautiful soup
and request libraries then we should
have a Hands-On selenium Webdriver then
we can learn selenium grade and then we
should have a Hands-On computer vision
using opencv Library
after these skills you can pursue a
career in web scraping and automation
testing if we talk about the average
salary for automation engineer that is
dollar 94
211 US dollars per year in the United
States as stated by the indeed.com on
21st December 2020. now to pursue any
career you should have your projects in
your portfolio using python to build
interactive projects will help you
develop useful coding skills your
self-confidence will increase as you
work on your projects which will also
help you in your comprehension of all
the programming ideas technical
expertise will be used to create an
appealing portfolio it is the finest
technique to demonstrate your coding
abilities to potential employers
everyone could Master the programming
language we discussed for different job
roles today but the real deal is to
implement your learnings as you enter an
interview
picture yourself stating I have a
respectable portfolio of projects I
learned about the company's future
endeavors aligning with my goals now who
could possibly reject it right
in particular businesses that want to
think creatively and pay convention to
create something remarkable will never
say no to such candidates
and with that we have come to the end of
this session
and I have an insightful for you guys if
you are aiming to get certified in
Python Programming and want to build a
python software development career in
that case you can check the python
certification course by simply learn
which will open the doors for the best
career opportunities and to find the
details of the Python certification
course you can check the link in the
description box below and it could be
the ideal solution to help you build
your career in the right direction well
that's a wrap for this video and I hope
the video was informative
thanks for watching subscribe to the
channel and stay tuned for more from
simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here